If you and your classmates were suddenly dying
in gruesome ways due to a horrifying curse,
what would you do?
You don't know how to stop this curse
and it's only a matter of time until it's your
turn to die.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat the curse
in another.
This kid is about to get everyone killed.
Koichi is not your average
youngster who wakes up in the hospital
after a collapsed lung and prepares
for his new life staying in Yomi Yama city.
And this is no ordinary city.
A few school classmates from Koichi,
his new school, pay him a visit
at the hospital, eerily introducing themselves
as ninth grade students in class three.
Little does
Koichi know that this class three will cost him
everything he loves in the coming months.
The three students redhead, girl, tall kid
and this glasses girl grill
Koichi left and right
and pry a little too much into his personal life
from asking where he came from,
why he's here and how long he's been here for.
Something is not right, and Koichi does his best
to answer all of their strange questions,
not realizing that they're just
doing their job to prevent
the most horrifying curse from reappearing again.
He's unaware that he will soon
be the cause for countless deaths.
They shake hands, and red haired girl asks Koichi
a final time if he's ever lived
in this town before, and then suddenly leaves
Koichi without uttering a word.
Okay, this is super weird, and frankly,
I'm uncomfortable as hell.
Students from a class I've never been to start
showing up to meet me is either really sweet
or really creepy,
and the fact that they were so intent on knowing
if I've lived here before, it makes me think
that they care way too much about who I am.
I don't even know them.
Now, this being 1997
means that we have no internet,
so I can't stalk them on Facebook or anything.
However, what I would do is look into the school
itself, either from old newspapers
or from word of mouth,
because if these three students
are as weird as hell,
then that probably means
that the rest of the school was indoctrinated
by the rest of them in the same way.
And looking into the source, the school itself
would allow me to gain some context into
why they were so concerned with my situation,
because there must be a reason for it.
100 push ups,
100 set ups, 100 squats and ten km runs.
Have you also started your journey
to become the strongest?
But now you're losing your hair?
What do you do?
Well, you get keeps, of course keeps.
It's a subscription service
that makes it easier and more affordable for men
to treat their male pattern baldness online
with online consultations with a real doctor.
Easy shipping and delivery right to your door.
two out of three guys will experience some type
of male pattern baldness by the time they're 35,
so the best way to prevent hair
loss is to do something about it
while you still have some hair left.
Keeps offers generic versions of FDA
approved medications for hair loss,
which makes it more affordable.
Their treatment typically takes between four
to six months to start seeing results,
so it's important to act fast.
The sooner you start using keeps, the more hair
you can save if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss.
Go to keep scar slash how to beat anime or click
the link below to get 50% off your first order.
Thank you guys for sponsoring this video,
and let's get back into it.
A few days later, Koichi
heads into the hospital lift as he sees
the strangest girl pop up right behind him.
Carrying a doll and startling Koichi Bud Koichi
sees that she's from the same school as him.
Koichi then pries into her life and asks
why she's heading
to the second basement level
because the only thing down there is the morgue.
The girl then says that she's delivering something
exiting the left before Koichi finds out
that her name is Mei Masaki,
plunging herself into the shrouded darkness
as she disappears before
Koichi has a chance to ask her more questions.
A week later, Koichi
finally recovered, begins life at his new school,
not knowing what hell awaits him
and is introduced to the teachers and class,
including Miss Mikami,
the assistant homeroom teacher.
Koichi then sits down and notices
Mei across the room from him.
The class then asks him all sorts of questions
about his life, including which part of Tokyo
he came from, and he sees Mei
all of a sudden disappear from her table,
almost as if
Koichi never saw her in the first place.
Failing to grasp just what horrors will soon
plague him and everyone in this classroom.
Later on in the day, Koichi sits out of gym
class and asks why his Class
Class three doesn't have gym class
with any other members in the school and classes.
Girl then says that Class three is different
and asks more strange
questions to Koichi about what
other classmates have told him about the school.
But Koichi just naively says nothing, blissfully
unaware of the sinister situation
that he's about to be in.
He then asks her if he's ever seen Misaki
anywhere, and that's when everything changes.
Glasses, girls face drawers pale and changes
dramatically.
She then says that she doesn't know
what he's talking about and cautiously
monitors his face,
knowing that he can't find out the truth.
Koichi then sees Mei on the building
rooftop and dashes off to see her.
Koichi gets to the top of the school and sees
Mei creepily standing watch over the town,
and he asks her
why she went to the second basement. The other.
A day, Mei says that something
very sad happened to her, but then suddenly
she changes the topic of conversation,
revealing to Koichi the most shocking news of all
that the entire class three now
associates Koichi his name with death
and not just any death, but a particular death
that took place at this very school.
Telling Koichi that this school is known
for its association to death, especially his class
class three made then says that Koichi shouldn't
try to get close to her
or to talk to her, saying that
he'll find out the reasons behind all of this soon
enough, leaving Koichi with more questions
than answers and nervous as hell.
Something is definitely going on
at the school, and Koichi will soon
wish that he was never here to begin with.
OK, this school is just as crazy as I thought.
And now everyone thinks I'm
some serious bad luck charm,
and this strange girl Mei is onto something
because if people are
already starting to ostracize me,
then that means that it probably won't be long
before I start getting bullied.
For whatever reason, they associate me with death.
And in Japan, I wouldn't be surprised.
As bullying in Japan is more common
than you think, with a record number of incidents
in a single year
as high as four hundred and 14,378 cases
from elementary right through Senior High School,
I'd actually listen to me and stay away from her.
No matter if I had the hots for her or not.
In fact, I do the opposite and throw a party
inviting the entirety of the Class
three to a thing.
At the very least, I begin to make more
of an effort to get to know everyone except me.
I'd also go to the class library
and ask around about the school death
that took place here and Meibe
even look into switching classes or schools.
This school seems way more creepy than I thought.
A few days later, Koichi runs into Blonde-haired
guy who runs his mouth and accidentally spills
the beans that his class Koichi.
His class is coerced.
This shocks Koichi, and everybody here
as blond guy just made a huge mistake,
and this grabs Koichiis attention
like a moth to a flame.
Blonde-haired guy finally says
that he's been wanting to tell Koichi something
for a while now,
but Koichi suddenly sees me in the library
and goes to chat with her before her Blonde-haired
guy gets the chance to talk more later at night.
Koichi pays the hospital
a visit and asks his nurse friend if a girl died
at this hospital last Monday,
the same day as Mei first met Koichi in the lift.
But the nurse is not sure
and thinks that there was someone
in another ward who died and agrees
to let Koichi know if she finds anything.
The next day, red haired girl confronts
Koichi during recess and asks even
more prying questions about his life
where he was born and his family situation.
As red haired girl knows she's met Koichi before,
but she can't pinpoint where or when.
Glass's girl
then tries to make Redhead Girl feel better,
but she says as head of countermeasures
that she has to do a better job.
She's fearful that if she fails, countless lives
will be lost in a matter of months.
And it's then when Koichi asks Just
what does a head of countermeasures do exactly
alerting the gang? Even more so.
Redhead Girl says that she's in charge of devising
and executing countermeasures
to protect the class,
but to protect her from what.
But Glass's girl stops redhead girl
from going into further detail
just as Koichiis attention
gravitates to me and leaves to follow her home.
Red haired girl knows what Koichi doesn't, that
if she doesn't let him in on the plan
soon, then everything they've worked so hard
for will get destroyed.
OK, this school
definitely has some skeletons in their closet,
and I wonder what and why did Koichi prioritize
following me over listening to Red Head Girl?
It makes sense that if there's a girl
who's head of countermeasures,
then that means that she would do everything
in her power to prevent
whatever it is that is going on in the school
from happening.
And one of the greatest preventative measures
would be public awareness as in letting Koichi
and on whatever the hell is going on,
because if he doesn't know,
then he won't be able to abide by whatever
countermeasures are in place to begin with.
Koichi shouldn't have left as quickly as he did,
but Red Head should have also explained everything
to Koichi from the start.
Koichi follows Mei to a strange doll shop
before he gets a call from the nurse
at the hospital, informing him
that someone did die last Monday.
A junior high school girl, this freaks Koichi out
as the nurse tries to save the dead girl's name.
The call abruptly gets cut.
Koichi, knowing what he knows.
Tries to compose himself as he enters
the eerie doll shop, where he meets the strange
old lady who welcomes him and mentions that he's
the first customer today to come into the shop.
Downstairs, he sees countless dolls.
Seeing one that looks just like me
and just then, like a genie in a bottle,
many pops up behind him, giving him a fright.
Something is not right with her, and she asks him
if he wants to see what's behind her
eyepatch, revealing to him
the most puzzling thing of all an artificial eye.
A dolls eye.
And mentioned that her doll eye sees things
that should not be seen puzzling Koichi
even further as to her creepy nature.
He then mentions to her that he heard a girl
died at the hospital the other day and asks me
if she has any sisters trying to connect her
in some way to the dead girl.
And Mei is confusing.
Koichi even further is Mei a ghost.
Koichi has more questions than answers.
As Mei warns him not to get too close to her, Mei
then reveals the most horrifying thing
that Koichi has ever heard.
She reveals to him
the town curse of Class 3:26 years ago.
She tells him about a student in the ninth grade
who died back then and whom the school's
teachers and classmates in a grief stricken state
started to pretend that she was still alive.
Even going so far
as to acknowledge her presence in class
and pretending to include her in the school photo
and the best part about all of this
the girl who died was named Misaki.
Mei then says that there's more to this story,
but Koichi is interrupted by his grandma,
who demands that he comes home this instant.
OK, this is weird as hell, but valuable
as Mei just gave us
a little context into the school death
that everyone is talking about.
However, I wouldn't just rely on this information
from one person, and if red head
or anyone from class won't tell us anything, then
I'd begin asking the people from outside of Class
three, starting with people in the higher grades,
as well as look into the school records
in the library to track down former students
of the class, kids and adults alike.
Because the one thing we're missing right now
is the whole picture, and it's clear
that my situation at the school hinges
on this death from all those years ago,
which means I likely won't be able
to forget about it, nor get past it
until we find all the missing pieces.
The next day, Koichi waits for the rain
to pass at the end of school and glasses
girl then asks Koichi
if she wants to walk home with her.
It is here that Koichi asks her
the most intense question ever
and asks What Mei Masaki is really like?
It is at this moment that glasses girl throws
terrified at the mere thought of Koichi question.
She then tells him to never speak of this
name in class three again.
Glasses girl sharks Koichi.
Just as Blonde-haireded kid interrupts
them, Koichi waste no time and asks both of them
if they know of the urban legend of Class
three from 26 years ago.
This question terrifies both Blonde-haireded
kid and glasses girl
right before the homeroom teacher
comes to put a stop to their questioning and says
that it's a very delicate issue
to discuss before sending everybody home.
Later on, Koichi has had enough of the mysteries
and calls Blonde-haireded
kid demanding that he tells them
just what the hell is going on.
Blonde-haireded kid then says that Koichi has made
Redhead Girl the head of countermeasures
extremely angry, before telling Koichi to chill
and to not mess with things that don't exist.
Blonde-haireded kid then tells Koichi
that he'll explain everything next month,
just as the phone gets cut off again
the next day during an exam, Koichi finishes
early and finds Mei chilling outside and discovers
that the girl who died at the hospital
was, in fact, Mei's cousin, Misaki Fujii
Oka shocking Koichi.
He then uses this opportunity
to pry more info from Mei
about what happened to Class 3:26 years ago.
And also, why does everyone in Class
three act like meh doesn't exist?
But Mei says to Koichi that only he can see her,
and this terrifies Koichi
at the thought of what could possibly be happening
is Mei a ghost can only he really see her?
These are the questions
and more that plague Koichi's
mind as he sees glasses girl running towards them,
who then gets shocked
at the very sight of Koichi and Mei before
running down the stairs in the other direction.
And that will be her final mistake.
Just then, she suddenly trips on the staircase,
losing her umbrella in the process and lands
right on the umbrella itself
with the metal tip of the umbrella
piercing through the back of her neck,
cutting through her like Japanese butter.
Hmm, that's good.
Well, I must say that this is too much
of a coincidence, and it's official.
There's a gosh darn curse up in here, and this is
also why you should never run down the stairs.
People always walk
because bad things can happen to good kids.
Now it's possible that she could have survived
if she was more lucky, provided
that the umbrella merely sliced through her muscle
or connective tissue.
But it doesn't seem that way, as penetrating neck
injuries that take place in or around the Platzer
are a major cause of morbidity and mortality
because of the vital structures
confined to this area , mainly the carotid
arteries that carry blood to the brain.
But it seems like this girl didn't get too lucky,
and the umbrella seemingly punctured her
larynx or windpipe.
Now I would suggest that we contact the girl's
family in order to notify them of her death.
I really don't care.
I say screw the girl and would be more interested
as to why she ran away the way she did
when she saw me and Mei.
Because does that mean that Mei is actually real?
That she's not a ghost?
This is all a mystery, and I love every bit of it.
The class looks upon the disgusting scene
in shock and horror, finding out later
that this girl's mother also died in an accident
that very same day.
Further confirming what?
Everyone is too scared to speak up
that the curse of Class three is back further,
sparking a series of gruesome deaths to come.
Starting with one person
every month, it being either a student
or someone connected to the class in some way,
and this means that no one is safe.
Later on during his checkup, Koichi meets.
His nurse friend and they decide to get lunch
together, and this is where Koichi finds out
that the nurse's brother told her that he thinks
the series of deaths were in fact not an accident.
Koichi asks the nurse
if she knows his friend Mei,
and that the very moment he began talking to her.
These accidents started to take place,
but the nurse thinks it's just a pure coincidence.
But we know better, and we also know that this is
only the beginning of more horrors to come.
Koichi also asks his nurse friend to ask her kid
brother about the events that happened to Class
3:26 years ago, and Koichi
is beginning to suspect that those events
and what's happening now is linked in some way.
Koichi then on the way home bumps
into a theater student from school,
and just then this giant glass frame
nearly crushes both of them to death.
And the theater career begins to break down
as she knows that this is only the beginning
of the curses wretched ways.
Well, that was a close one, and now it seems like
this curse is out to get me to.
Or Meibe just this girl.
Meibe I could use her if I have to.
And if I was Koichi,
I would have probably been a reverse gentleman
and let her die right here and now
and taken a step back and let Gravity do its work
because this only temporarily
prevented our turn to roll with death.
And now who knows when the next time death
will come at our doorstep?
Saving her only altered what's to inevitably
come back to us like the butterfly effect in chaos
theory, the butterfly effect
is the sensitive dependance on initial conditions
in which a small change
in one state of a deterministic nonlinear system
can result in large differences in a later state,
meaning that this single tiny change here is going
to cause a large consequence down the road.
Because the only thing that we do know
at this point is that something bad is happening
around us, which means it's past time
we start to recruiting some allies.
Koichi thinks something is definitely afoot here
and heads to the doll shop again at the doll shop.
He meets me,
and she mentions that the entire class and
even her think that the curse has already begun.
But Koichi still doesn't know
what the hell she's talking about and demands
to know once and for all
everything that she's speaking about.
But Mei thinks it's better that he doesn't know
and leaves him to stew in his own
terrified thoughts.
Back at home, Kouchi talks with his aunt,
who since he began
his new school, has suddenly started
to get headaches, and Koichi discovers
that his aunt, 15 years ago, was in the same class
three as Koichi.
He asks her if the curse of Class three
was still around back then,
but she says that she doesn't remember anything.
Koichi should have realized the sooner
this talk will cost him everything.
The next day, the class discusses
if the curse is truly back, wondering
if it's all just a coincidence,
or if it's all because of Koichi even discussed
bringing up the situation to him.
And if it's too late or too dangerous now
to do anything, the class then decides to treat
Koichi it the same way they treated me
by pretending he doesn't exist,
but they don't realize that it's already too late
to stop what's coming for them.
Koichi then during break, finds Blonde-Haired
Guy and tells him that it's been a month
and that he now has the right to know
just what the hell is going on here.
But Redhead Girl tells Koichi
to not ask any questions.
Just then,
Koichi gets a phone call from the nurse,
who tells him that her brother refused to speak of
what happened to Class 3:26
years ago, and that her brother also doesn't know
who the hell Mei Masaki was.
Which means either he's lying
or Mei really doesn't exist.
And it's all in Koichi head.
But the call is cut short again,
and suddenly the elevator brakes don't work
and the entire thing comes crashing down
like a descending coffin, crushing
the nurse more so than crushed strawberries.
Well, this is horrible.
This nurse lady was really our only friend
and valuable source of information
aside from me, and we can't afford
to be losing friends at a time like this.
But in reality, there was little chance
our nurse friend could have survived.
The only one possible way would be to lay
on your back in the center of the lift,
as this will distribute the force of impact
over the greatest area of your body
so that no particular part of your body
is subjected
to the entire weight
of any other part of your body.
And even if you did this,
you probably still would have been lacerated
by the debris collected on the lift floor.
And no jumping right at the last second before
the left would have crashed would not have helped.
But the good news is is that our friends likely
felt no pain in the process, meaning our nurse
friend's brain was likely to slow to realize
or feel pain or suffering at all.
Well, that's too bad.
In the coming days, the news of the nurse's
death plagues the school,
as everyone knows, but is too afraid to speak
about what is really going on.
The curse of Class three is back,
and it's already begun.
At school,
the class is deep in thought within a deep self
study session as their homeroom teacher,
Miss Mikami, is sick.
Or so it appears
Koichi decides to head to the library and dives
deep into the school records
to see if Mei is within the history books
, as he still suspects something is off about her,
but that's when he sees it.
His mother in the class of 1972 yearbook
finding out that his mother
was in the very same class as him.
Later on, the police questioned Koichi
about the nurse's death, concluding that her death
was indeed an accident and that the building
itself was also several decades old.
But Koichi knows something isn't right.
Koichi walks home with some friends
when they discuss the strange disturbances
that have been going on, as they say
that the class has been discussing some stuff
regarding Koichi, and that's something
very unpleasant might happen to him very soon.
Koichi then asks them for a favor
to get a copy of the class roster,
as one of the friends ends up feeling
sorry for Koichi
and says that he'll tell him everything
about what's really going on.
No more secrets.
But just then, as Koichi asks the friend
if Mei exists, his heart
suddenly starts convulsing and the friend ends up
collapsing to the ground dead.
OK, this is more serious than we think.
As before, all we saw were coincidental deaths
that looked like accidents
transpired through outside forces.
But this is the first time
we're seeing a death happen within ourselves.
Meaning,
unlike what we're down in Final Destination,
this curse doesn't need to kill us
and some fancy elaborate way and can
literally kill us by making us drop
dead right here right now.
And what's even more strange
is that according to world life expectancy rt.com,
Japan has one of the lowest rates
of coronary heart failure, with a rate of 31.5,
whereas the highest is Turkmenistan
with a rating of 379.3
and this kid dying happening right
as he tried to tell us what was really going on.
This might say it's getting past coincidental.
If I was Koichi, I test out how on the ball
this curse really is by going in guns blazing.
And by that,
I mean, I would literally go into class three
and yell my lungs out
about what really is going on with this curse,
because so far, Koichi has tried
approaching this softly.
But now I think it's time to go and loud
and proud.
Also by me asking the entire class in one go.
Worst case, more classmates will die, who offered
to tell me the truth, as it seems that way
based on my last friend who died
right before he told me best case.
At least someone will finally cave in
and let me in on what's really going on.
Like I said, Class three following the rules
will only work if everyone is in the know which.
That alone makes it
practically foolish and impractical as to why
they haven't let me and fully on what's going on
when their survival
also depends on my actions as well,
since I'm also in Class three.
It seems like 87% I have subscribed
to help us with the algorithm and subscribe now.
The class mourns yet
another death as Koichi soon begins to find out
that it's official, the class has begun to pretend
that he doesn't exist.
Ignoring his questions and his efforts
and grabbing their attention, he's becoming
just like meh.
After school, Koichi gets a note of the class
roster, which leads him to head straight to me.
He tells her of the student who died
and that the class has started to ignore him.
But now Koichi's thoughts on me as a ghost
finally dissipate,
realizing that the class was simply ignoring her
the whole time.
We also find out that Mei lives right
above the doll shop as her mom owns the shop
and is the creepy reason
why so many of the dolls look like her.
How adorable Mei then finally decides
to catch him a break, and she decides
to spill the beans on the whole curse,
saying that the Masaki, who died
26 years ago was the triggering event
that began this curse in the first place.
From then on, drawing Class three closer to death
beginning the year after Masaki
classmates graduated from Class three,
causing a nearly yearly cycle
that begins with one student dying each month.
Once the curse begins, beginning
only when the total number of students
within class three increases by one person,
but the class
has never been able
to figure out who the extra person was.
25 years ago, shortly after the new term began,
they realized they were short, one desk
and one chair, even though they had prepared
enough for every student and checking the school
records were pointless as they are constantly
altered, with everyone's memories being wiped out.
Each time this happens, and Mei
then reveals the most shocking thing of all,
the extra person in class is dead,
but doesn't know they are already dead
and are made of flesh and bone
just like the rest of everybody else.
But until they find out who the extra dead
classmate is, people
will keep dying
because of what Class three did 26 years ago.
By ignoring a dead student, this is the reason why
they are known as a place that invites the dead.
This is why the class has countermeasures in place
to help the class try and escape this curse
and why they have red head girl
as head of countermeasures, and the reason why
the class pretends that only one person in class
doesn't exist to make up
for the extra student by ignoring one in class.
OK, this is actually insane.
If I was Koichi, I would see
if there was a history of anyone switching classes
from Class three into another class,
because that would definitely be on the records
and we could see for ourselves to what to.
Degree of separation, does this curse affect us,
and this includes trying to see
if it would be possible to eliminate the class
entirely, thereby moving all students to the rest
of the other classes, effectively increasing
all the class numbers by an extra few students.
Granted, this Mei not work, but I don't see
anyone else doing anything other than following
whatever rules they are following right now,
which are obviously not stopping this curse
from still killing people.
So we might as well try something new.
As the curse progresses,
the teachers become more vigilant and cautious
about the whole situation, warning the class
not to tell any outsiders.
Later, Koichi then goes to Mei's house again
and Mei let Koichi know that she knows
who the extra person is.
But just as she's about to say it, her mom
enters and spoils
the gang's investigation,
forcing them to take their talk outside.
And Koichi finds out that the class decided
to brilliantly bolster security measures
by pretending that two people don't exist
now him and Mei
the next day they meet in the library
and they find out that the librarian has been here
since the start, and he was class
three's homeroom teacher way back,
and he lets them in further
on how the curse works.
He says that the ones in most danger are either
the related family members of the students,
if not the students themselves,
and only towards people who live in this town,
and that the curse gets weaker
the further you go out of town.
The librarian then shows them the history of class
rosters from when the curse began.
Up until now, telling them
that when the curse is active, it
mysteriously alters the records and the people's
memories of everything, including the deceased,
revealing that there's no way to beat this curse
other than pretending someone in Class
three doesn't exist.
That is, if they can handle being mistreated
this way, all seems lost until the next day.
The teacher walks in, places a bag on his desk
and then all of a sudden brings out
a knife and plunges it into his neck
right in front of everyone.
Well, this is next level insanity.
This is just gone from people dying in mysterious
accidents to full line stabbing themselves.
first, it was the kid with the heart attack,
and now people are willingly taking their own life
in public.
At this point, I don't even think only Class three
could be talking about this curse.
I would imagine a teacher killing themselves
during school time would not only alert
the entire school, but also the local news,
and this would result into more inquiries
into Class three.
And honestly, this is our best bet
because no one seems to talk about this curse
with people outside of the class,
but this could be our best chance
and letting people on the outside
to help us, or at the very least report on it,
so we could get some differing opinions on
what the hell is really going on.
It was beyond foolish to not let anyone else
in on the situation all this time.
The teachers withered corpse lays in
front of everybody, forcing the class to evacuate
and await for what's to come.
The police also find even more disturbing evidence
that the teacher not only lived with his mother
but killed her, leaving her body
to rot inside their home.
Later, redhead girl talks to Koichi
that people will blame him as well as her
for everything that's happened.
But she thinks that this is only the beginning,
and sadly, she's right on the money.
Later, Koichi and Mei go and talk to the librarian
about the only time the car stopped
mid-year 25 years ago,
when the class went on a trip to somewhere,
somehow mysteriously
causing the curse to stop mid August.
And they even visited a shrine, discussing
if this has something to do
with stopping the curse
or if it's all a coincidence.
But this doesn't stop the school
from announcing that the class will soon
be conducting the very same trip in the coming
month of August, hoping to repeat what happened
all those years ago.
Later, Koichi gets a call from Blonde-haired
Kid, asking him to come to a restaurant
where he also finds red
head girl at the restaurant.
Red haired girl again
swears she's met Koichi before,
but is coincidentally distracted
just as Blonde-haireded kid shows up late.
It is here where the waitress tells one of them
that one of her regulars was also
in class three years ago
and claims to have stopped the curse himself,
claiming that he left a hint somewhere
to help the future generation stop the curse.
But he can't remember where,
but they don't know how to find him
until they find out
that this guy was his aunt's classmate, Mo.
If this guy supposedly saved Class three
all those years ago and even had a clue on
how to beat this curse,
then it is possible that he could have
also told others about how to beat it,
which could result in others also taking it
upon themselves to leave a clue somewhere.
But the infuriating problem is
is that no one remembers much of anything.
If I was them, I would begin questioning
each member of Class three from the past,
and the information is available in the library.
And this way we could get a better picture by
questioning all of the past class three members.
Now, no one Mei remember much, but we might
get something, but we won't know until we ask.
It is highly unlike.
Likely that with how seriously Class
three takes this curse, that no one
and all of these years, wouldn't have tried
to leave some sort of valuable information
behind for future generations to find,
even if the information was helpful or not?
Koichi then at home, asks his aunt more about
this guy and the class trip that everyone took.
But his aunt can't seem to coincidentally remember
much, but agrees to help
talk to him with Koichi.
The next day, the gang decides to arrange a trip
to the beach to meet this guy,
and this black haired kid even joins them.
But that was his biggest mistake.
The class and a sick classmate
along with the aunt head to the beach
just as the mystery man who supposedly
stop the curse all those years ago shows up.
But he can't seem to remember a damn thing,
only that he left a clue somewhere at the school.
Just then, a massive wind picks up the gang's ball
and throws it into the ocean.
And this black haired kid,
the guy who was puking the whole ride here
offers to get the ball, not realizing
that he'll never come back to shore alive.
This black haired kid then swims out into the sea,
chasing after the ball.
Only he slowly stops swimming, and the view
of his body in the distance becomes faint.
Koichi and the gang tense up in fear of the worst,
but just then his head pops up, showing
that all is fine and is continuing to get the ball
until he faints again.
Koichi and the gang frantically try to get to him,
but just then notice a boat heading
right for black haired kid.
The boat rams right through him, tearing
his corpse into pieces, letting up the water.
The shocked group stands knee deep in water,
paralyzed with fear, right as the claimed savior
for Class three, this guy utters in shock
that he left a hint in the classroom,
leaving a tape somewhere behind.
That's where they need
to look to find out how to stop this curse.
Oh my gosh, this was insane.
And this kid died way too quickly.
And no, I'm not talking about getting ripped apart
by the boat.
I'm talking about drowning.
There's nothing like the feeling of being helpless
at sea, with no sense of direction
getting submerged further
and further into the depths by cascading waves,
forcing you to with all of your might try and swim
upward, exhausting your entire body
until you can barely reach the surface,
forcing your mouth to gape wide open
and finally inhale the salt water
and you slowly lose consciousness.
Fun fact Did you know that drowning is actually
the third leading cause of unintentional injury
death globally, with an estimated 236
annual drowning
deaths worldwide, with children and males
being the greatest at risk?
The only thing that Cade could have done
was to stop swimming and to not exhaust himself
trying to fight the current,
and then he needs to identify
any such rip currents,
and he needs to swim parallel to the shore
to get out of the rip currents path
by looking to swim toward the direction
of the nearest to break waves, marking
the end of the rip current.
But let's be honest with this curse going around,
there's little chance
he wasn't already dead that day to begin with.
Later, back at Yomiyama City, the gang finds out
the most horrifying thing that the event
that led to black haired kid's death
actually took place in the of town itself.
He hit his head at home
and caused a cerebral contusion within his brain
to form right before he left for the beach.
This means that no one in this town is safe
and anyone could be next.
Koichi knows that time is running out and talks
with Blonde-haireded kid telling him to not tell
anyone that he thinks that the tape is hidden
somewhere in the classroom.
Agreeing to meet up tomorrow at the school
to look for it the next day, Mei finds out
that Koichi and the group are planning
to look for the tape and agrees to join them.
They scour through the closed door floor
and search through the numerous classrooms
there in another part of town.
The kid from acting class
tells her friend that her family is planning
to leave Town for good,
and she bids her friends goodbye,
not realizing that this carefree attitude
will lead to her death.
Back at the school, the group finally finds
the tape taped behind a locker.
They quickly put it inside a tape recorder and
begin to hear what will only shock them further.
On the tape,
they hear the adult the friend of Koichiis aren't.
We met earlier
who goes into depth of what happened
all those years ago
and how he beat the terrible curse.
He says that his class left road trip
out of town to pay respects
to a shrine
that they hoped would help stop the curse.
Cleaning it up in the process
But they learned that this tactic was useless,
and this leads to two of their members
dying as they went down the hill from the shrine,
with one dying of a lightning strike
and one falling off of the cliff entirely.
But just then, in the midst of the tapes
recording, a teacher walks in, forcing the gang
to hide, resulting in the tape getting wrecked,
not getting to hear the most important part.
But one of the classmates agrees
to try and fix it.
And so the gang waits.
Okay, this was all types of bad to begin with.
Your best bet during a lightning storm is
to get off of any hell or high ground immediately.
Now that thunderstorm was insane.
And likely violated the 30 rule,
which is a rule used to for thunderstorms
counting to 30 at the moment,
you see a lightning strike and if you hear thunder
before the 32nd count is up,
then that means the thunderstorm is close
enough to be dangerous,
which in this case, it clearly was.
Now, the gang wasn't near any proper shelter,
so their best bet in that case
would be to stop running and go fetal.
And by that, I mean, curling up into a ball
with your head tucked in and your hands over
your ears, minimizing your contact with the ground
and being as low as humanly possible.
They also would have done better to stay away
from isolated trees and bodies of water.
Trying to run during a lightning storm
was probably the worst thing
they could have done elsewhere.
We see the same kid from drama class,
the one who met up with Koichi die
as the family car gets hit with a falling rock,
causing the entire car
to derail and run off the road,
killing everybody inside.
The day of the fateful class trip
outside of town arrives
and the gang takes up room at this giant mansion.
Little did they know that by the end of this,
almost all of them will die.
The group also finally fixes the tape and wasted
no time in hearing the last bit of it.
The man who stopped the curse
all those years ago continues to recount the story
and says that once they came down from
the mountain, he got into a fight with another
mysterious student and whom he ended up
accidentally killing in the process.
The strangest thing was that by the next morning,
the body was gone reading any evidence
of what had taken place,
and on top of that, everyone from his class
didn't even know who he was talking about.
It's almost as if they had their memories wiped,
and the class roster even revealed
19 students on the trip,
not 20, meaning this man accidentally
killed the extra students
and ended the curse in the process.
The group now knows what to do.
They need to find the extra students
and kill them to stop the curse.
Only there's no way to tell the living
from the dead and to top it all off,
the extra person doesn't even know they are dead,
which means they need to create a plan
to sift through all of the other students
and find the dead person later at dinner.
A tense air arises as everyone sits on edge,
knowing that
one of them will be next and they are right.
Just then, one of the students starts choking,
finding out that he has asthma.
But he has used up his inhaler, resulting
in the librarian to drive him to the hospital.
This is it, folks. It's Showtime.
This curse is literally about to kill everyone,
which means I stand a better chance of surviving
if I eliminate everyone else.
There's little chance that at this point
we'll find the students,
so I would begin to take matters
into my own hands.
first up, I would round up a few students that
I know I could control, specifically redhead girl.
And I would begin killing all of the students
after dinner, killing them in their own rooms
as they rest by working together
with one or two members to stab, slit,
puncture, choke, smother
and basically kill every student in the hotel ,
which wouldn't be hard since it's mostly
filled with unsuspecting students anyways.
Then, after the deed is done,
I would find the remaining members
and congratulate them for helping me with my plan.
And when they least suspecting it,
I would kill them too,
which would ultimately cover my bases
in finding out who the extra person is.
Mei later in the room confesses to Koichi
that her cousin is in fact her twin sister,
revealing that it was her that she was visiting
in the hospital on that night
when she first met Koichi.
But that's not all.
Mei also then finally reveal something
even more insane.
She reveals that her artificial doll
I can see the dead and the living.
She can tell when someone is about to die,
and this is the reason that she keeps it covered.
Koichi is shocked and asks her
if she knows who the dead extra person is.
But just then Blonde-haireded
kid busts into the room, saying that he messed up
and accidentally killed a student
in other parts of the hotel.
Redhead Girl discusses with this glasses girl
about me and suspect that she is, in fact,
the extra person because red haired girl swears
that she went to school with a girl
who looked just like me.
But that girl was not missing an eye,
which to them means that Mei is the culprit.
Back in Koichi Room, Blonde-haireded kid tells him
that he thought that his friend this glasses guy
was the extra student
and accidentally killed him in the process,
making him topple over the balcony
during an argument.
The gang agrees to go check on him first
before anyone else does something drastic,
just as they run into another student
to leading in the hallway.
But that's not all.
Koichi then looks in the dining room
and sees the manager in.
They're brutally stabbed and the room is on fire.
They need to get out of there.
But just then, the rest of the class comes
to check out the ruckus.
And they all think that the same person
who stabbed this kid started the fire.
Koichi then alerts everyone that there's a fire
and they decide to go, tell the homeroom
teacher Miss Mikami of what's going on,
but she's nowhere to be found.
Just then, this glasses girl appears and claims
Mei is the extra person and needs to die.
She lunges at me and Koichi blocks her attack.
Red head girl then explains that Glass is.
Girl found the tape that they listened to earlier
and that she is emotionally unstable
and out of control, and just then
they hear the most terrifying sound glasses.
Girl is on the speaker and she tells everyone
that Mei is the extra person
and demands that all the classmates help
in killing Mei classes.
Girl continues saying that they both went
to the same elementary school together.
But now Mei is suddenly missing an eye,
meaning that she was reborn.
Incomplete, complete glasses girl
then tells everyone that they need to kill me
to stop the curse,
and everyone readies their makeshift weapons with.
This is a real Lord of the Flies situation
going on here.
I love it now.
The easy thing would have been to kill me first,
obviously to appease the others.
But let me ask you, what if we kept me alive?
Since she seems kind of evil and weird,
and just like our editor Al, well, in that case,
I would have ran downstairs
and out into the forest as we would have had
a better chance of surviving outside than here,
or I would have gone into the kitchen since.
That's where we'll have the best chance
of finding some weapons.
And if I holed up in there making a makeshift
kill corridor where I would proceed to stab
anyone who approached the doorway and slowly
but surely making my way through all of the kids.
Now, the third option would be more risky,
but Glass's girl and redhead seem to have
the most influence here, so I would concentrate
my efforts on finding glasses girl
first and locate the powder room where she was
held up before killing her that little bitch.
And then I would barricade myself in there
and use the public intercom to blame the
whole situation on Glasses Girl, which was that
glasses girl was emotionally unstable
and that we can't trust her
redhead would most likely be on my side in this.
Judging by the way,
she reacted to glasses girl statement,
which would allow us to save Mei
and not die in the process.
The entire school shows up ready to kill me,
but accidentally killed the homeroom teacher,
Miss Mikami, in the process, and the duo barely
escapes through the hallway and down the stairs.
They are confronted by glasses, girl
and the stairway.
But as they fight glasses, girl gets tangled up
by wires and accidentally dies.
The mansion
then blows up and kills even more students.
But then red haired girl shows up and blames
the death of Glass's girl on Mei
herself, forcing Mei to run away from Koichi
to not put him in further danger.
Outside, the librarian brings out
some injured students while back inside,
we see this glasses guy who thinks the dead person
is Koichi and attacks him,
almost killing him until redhead saves him
so she can kill him for herself.
But she is stopped by the librarian
who has had enough killing for one day.
He then says for everyone to get out,
but Koichi stays in desperately
looking for me as he runs around
sifting through the burning rubble and smoke.
But the battle is not over as he runs into me,
but also red haired girl
who truly thinks Mei is the dead
student and battles Koichi,
who defense Mei just a long enough
until a massive explosion erupts right in
front of them, causing red head girl
to get impaled by shards of glass on her deathbed.
She remembers that she actually met Koichi before
and that he actually isn't a new student,
but one who has been here for a while
but had his memory wiped after she dies.
Koichi gets a call from Mei,
telling him that she has to stop it.
The curse must end.
She begs Koichi to not come to her,
but that doesn't stop him.
He reaches Mei and finds out that the extra person
is none other than the homeroom teacher
Miss Mikami.
Mei tells him that she sees the color of death
on Miss Mikami and that she's known for a while.
Upon realizing this,
she also realizes that she actually witnessed
Miss Mikami death prior to the school year,
with her body being dumped in the dam.
They must kill her to stop the calamity
as she is already dead.
Koichi grabs the pickax
and readies himself to kill Miss Mikami,
but he suddenly realizes that his aunt
has also been dead this whole time in shock.
He finally strikes the killing blow
and sends her Miss Mikami to the afterlife,
ending this curse for good.
Hey, guys,
thank you so much for checking out this video.
Thank you.
And please subscribe.
Hit the thumbs up
and go into the comment section below
and let us know what you like,
what you didn't like.
And also please
check out our playlist and our social media.